the waters between britain and france
are turbulent and difficult this is
where the impact of brexit will be felt
not in politics but in tangible cold wet
real life
right now european fishing boats can
enter these waters freely
so we've joined the french vessel lord
jeffrey out of bologna and hunting for
crabs and soul
the boat's captain has followed his
father and grandfather into this job
he doesn't fear weather or waves but he
is nervous
about brexit
[Music]
we are really frightened that a hard
brexit will prevent us from fishing in
british waters
the majority of our fishing happens in
these waters and so for us that would be
the end of our jobs
night falls and the work is arduous on
this trip they'll catch more than 200
kilos of fish and seafood
the challenge is to get it back to port
while it's fresh
time is pressing everywhere brexit talks
are deadlocked without a deal
european boats may be barred from areas
they've fished for generations
night gives way to morning we cross an
invisible frontier
well we've moved from french waters and
gone into british coastal waters
so what you're seeing is a french vessel
hauling up nets full of fish and seafood
that have been caught in british coastal
waters that's been legal now for
decades but if that framework were to
change it would have
huge repercussions for the fishing
industry in britain
and across europe we return to berlin
the fish will be unloaded and sold at
the keysight
and among these stalls there is pride in
defiance
emily sells the lobsters that her
partner catches knowing our fishermen
they better warn the police over there
because they'll go out fishing anyway
it's like the french fishing industry is
being allowed to die out but the foreign
industry can survive
it's not normal across the dark other
holes are sold at the daily auction
bought by food companies suppliers and
restaurants
british fishermen sell their catches
here too
[Music]
seoul sea snail sea bass all of them
more popular with european customers
than in the uk sold in the line
dispatched
across the continent you the british
you need to exploit your fishing zones
but you aren't able to do this alone
you need the european market to sell a
whole series of products that you don't
really consume
and we also need you for such supplies
around us the lorries leave fish landed
this morning will be eaten tonight in
paris berlin and in brussels which is
where a future fishing deal
occupies the minds of the politicians
brexit negotiations are contentious and
difficult
xavier bellamy wrote the european
parliament's report into the fishing
industry
he told me europe was prepared to
compromise but that he fears the
backlash if a deal can't be done
we need to find a partnership if we
don't do so this social and economic
difficulties that we will face will
result
obviously in tensions and and
maybe in big clashes
at sea between between british and
other european fishermen which would be
a catastrophe back at the dock the
fishermen prepare for another day at sea
a fishing deal will require compromise
and
realism on both sides but this is an
industry
that knows about patients